so in this talk I'm going to be going
through a series of scenarios which I
will put to you these are real life
scenarios it's based on work that I've
done as an investigative data journalist
so the interesting aspect of this talk I
think for technologists and protect
companies and for businesses is there's
been a lot of noise about big data about
user data large streams of data which
they can aggregate which will then
smooth out the outliers and maybe try
make business decisions from I'm looking
at data at a very very different angle
rather than a telescopic view my job was
to look at data and a microscopic view
did tear things apart and to wonder why
the outliers were there and maybe what
we can do with joining with data looking
with data and getting newsworthy stories
and insights particularly from them in
that sense I'm looking more at the
decisions in terms of a news story in
terms of more like business decisions is
this analysis good enough to make
business decisions on revenue decisions
user decisions pivoting decisions
product decisions but first of all I
should tell you a bit about myself
because this journey will take you
through a lot of my career in the
previous places I've worked i started
off actually as a broadcast journalist
TV journalist as CNN international in
london the first story starts there i
was then awarded a knight mozilla
fellowship open news fellowship and
embedded at the Guardian for a year at
their interactive team I was editorial
even though Mozilla is a technology
company they actually looked at
technologists people were interested in
using computers and media to actually go
into the news rooms and work directly
with the editorial journalists to try
and change their I view on how they
actually do their journalism from there
I got a job as a investigative data
journalist which is a very very
particular position where my beat was
everything in anything that I could use
a computer to get at all digital media
from there I have pivoted and went
completely
development because of my love of
computer so much and I now currently
work at four works based in London so
I'm going to start this off with a story
with something that actually is a
particularly strange loop it goes from
it goes from a random conversations to
hardcore drugs to Twitter to a homeless
shelter to LinkedIn and all the way to
central government and this again was a
loop created from sheer boredom and
frustration so I graduated from
University at the worst possible time in
history at the height of the global
recession I tried to enter an industry
that was contracting and had a lot of
issues with technology and advertising
even before the recession and so my
first job was turning the dial of the
autocue in the news gallery that
involves doing this and semi regular
intervals something you could train a
monkey for and you could probably now
program that i could probably a program
that oh but i was working part-time and
I was mostly in the news gallery the
news gallery is the back studio which
runs what you would see on TV so all the
cameras most time there isn't someone
behind the camera that is all on stages
and all on trolleys and that's been one
electronically as is audio as is all the
visual effects and the audio and visual
effects guys were really really cool
they were also very very much into music
being into music they're very very much
into raves and underground dance parties
being very much into that they were into
experimenting with drug cocktails this
was a something I didn't have any
experience in but I was listening to
this in the news gallery I decided I
wanted to find more I wanted to find out
who were making these drug cocktails
where were they getting them from and
who was experimenting with them and
where was this market this underground
market and so I had a computer in front
of me and I did what traditional
journalist would go out and do what they
would go out into the world they would
go undercover I went undercover online
and I started to Twitter accounts
and with these Twitter accounts I was
basically mimicking the conversations
that I were hearing and then keywords
key drug cocktails people will start
following me and I would start following
them and I started then building I'm a
network of conversations of people in
this underground network underground
drug Network the interesting thing that
it led me to was and something
particular I think to the UK and it
spread to Europe which is called squat
parties so to have a massive underground
rave party spontaneously happen you need
a large venue you need it probably to be
abandoned and you need to get a critical
mass you need within the first 30
minutes to probably have around the
thousand people there um you also need
what's called a squat notice you can
print these out there are legal notices
that you can put on two abandoned
buildings to say that you are squatting
there what that does say is that the
police can't then break down the door
they have to go and get a legal permit
to break the squat notice so what they
realize is that combined with a squat
notice hell of a lot of people a lot of
noise the local police force or our
bobbies on the beat they don't have guns
they've got like the funny hats and like
a stick come knocking on the door they
ain't gonna do anything they're not
going to have the time they're gonna let
this party burn out and what happens is
that a lot of people that go to these
parties also burn out and so I was
hearing about these parties and I was
wondering how they got there how do you
manage to get a squat notice to get
sound equipment to get a stage up to get
odd full deck and to get a hell of a lot
of drugs and a thousand people ready in
30 minutes I knew this had to be done
online but from the conversations there
was a lot of people I needed to talk to
these people in person rather than being
on Twitter they weren't going to
actually pass anything out on Twitter so
one of the conversations I heard was a
guy saying I'm completely burnt out
absolutely and completely burnt out I
need some place quiet to stay I can't
stay at the squat parties anymore I
happened to volunteer at a homeless
shelter and so one of my twitter
accounts then sent them a message with a
link to this homeless shelter
and I knew that this person also spoke
French and so I turn up at the homeless
shelter and there's two guys speaking
French looking very very much the worse
for wear quite young not from the UK
mostly immigrants interesting
backstories I start talking to them and
the first thing when the guy does is
tell me about his crazy raves and
invites me to go like give me your
details and i'll let you know when this
happening when this is happening i'll be
your contact I Bay said you know the
rules here can't give out my details and
so all of these people have smartphones
everyone at homeless shelters has a
smartphone if not an iPad he then sends
me a link and he's like this is a
company that runs entertainment rave
entertainment but they have a newsletter
signup he's like sign up for the
newsletter with not your email address
but with a phone number put your phone
number in there and you will get a text
message and you need to get to this
place within three hours that's how they
do it and so I have an email address
from an email address i do a whois
lookup from whois lookup I aside from a
website to whois lookup I get an email
address get an email address of the
person that owns this company um what I
then do in terms of data is I want to
find out more about this person and the
best place is not to go door knocking
and not to do pick up the phone
traditional journalism it's look on the
web so what I do have is I have and I
have I make an email account a brand new
gmail account and I put in my contacts
list this email address and with that
new email account I sign up for LinkedIn
and the first thing you do when they
sign up to onboard you is can we have
access to your contacts to find your
friends it is a backdoor into their
database of emails and so this person I
find a unique identifier this person's
email is a unique identifier and I find
what this person does for a living this
person is an Internet architect he's a
technologist his side company which I
cannot name I cannot name him um I
actually set up rave clubs but his
full-time job as an engineer architect
is an Internet architect at a company
which I cannot name but they work in a
bank transactions monetary transactions
a lot of the ATM transactions that are
free that go on in the UK they also
looked into the company on a company's
account or there's an open web site
called open corporates to look up more
about this company and from there
getting their unique company number i
also had previously scraped a list of
government contracts and this company is
contracted by Her Majesty's service to
do the piye system all of our tax system
is done through the technology built by
this guy and so this is where I realized
there's very interesting uses in doing
seeding out small bits of data that
Twitter was very nascent at that time
and I was not using Twitter for what
they wanted me to use I would be an
outlier in terms of their use cases and
it's not what they made their product
for the same thing with all social media
networks things like LinkedIn where they
want you to on board come give me your
contacts I will do an immediate look up
into my database they probably don't
like the fact that I did that but
there's probably very little that they
can do and so that kind of put me on
track for using a computer better using
a computer more learning to scrape
learning to program and so from that I
want to go through a series of work that
I've done and I'm going to ask you is it
a bug or is it a story and what I mean
by bug nets were is not in this sort of
agile Kanban card of oh is this a bug in
the code that we need to fix before we
deploy or is this a feature what I mean
is more the lines of okay is this
something legitimate that you should
make business decisions off or is this a
bug in the data because bug bugs and
data are very very different to bugs in
code because there's a lot of
mostly goes down to misinterpretation
and it usually goes down to how the data
was collected or how the data was
analyzed a lot of analysis you can throw
all sorts of data into and no program
will tell you you're not analyzing this
correctly they will just do the maths
for you so let's start with probably one
of the latest and the biggest stories I
worked on so if people here are into
soccer which um football you you might
know of the FIFA files which was the
Sunday Times expose of the email leaked
from Mohammed bin hammam for the Cathar
2020 bid this investigation led to a
series of investigations from the times
and from other papers which recently led
to the resignation of set bladder from
FIFA and I worked on these emails they
were leaked to us but they were in the
form of PDFs that were locked and
journalistically previously they would
have printed everything out and gone
through things by hand I know our
lawyers actually still do that I would
just literally use PDF minor PDF to text
unlock everything convert everything to
text and do some text mining for two
from BC PCC and CC and built this
network diagram the person at the very
very center of the tree top there is
Mohammed bin hammam secretary and the
person in yellow I cannot show you these
names directly but the person in yellow
is set Blatter and I want to ask you
having done this from leaked emails from
a source who I did not know the source i
did not speak to the source other
journalists did i just had the data is
this publishable is this a bug or is it
a story should this image be published
okay so hands up who thinks this is a
story this is data that we have done I
have not manipulated the data I have
convert
PDF to text I've taken out names I've
connected them with CC BCC to and from
hands up who thinks it's a story okay
hands up who thinks it's a bug this is
actually a bug because it is one node it
is partial data our source we assume had
access to an server Microsoft Outlook
server and went into one person's
account we don't know if they took every
single email this person cherry picked
the emails and if you look back as well
the person is at the center because
that's the person's emails that they had
access to all of the nodes on the trees
they could end up if we get a much
bigger picture and get their emails and
everyone that they've email connected to
FIFA we could get a very very different
picture and that is one of the big
things when it comes to making decisions
based on data is the unknown unknowns it
is very very difficult to say how much
data you are losing and with big data
they think that it's only going to be a
small percentage and it's fine but a lot
of time that percentage is not know in
terms of losing data it can also be a
misinterpretation of how you got that
data so doing business intelligence for
a news organization the time sometimes
behind a paywall so we have user
accounts that they log into so you can
track individual users we have
information on those users like gender
and actually like how much they earn one
point we wanted to look at what our
female users were doing because we had
very low volume of female users and then
how we can make and change our content
to suit them and maybe we should have a
special supplement maybe we should have
some of our female writers work on a
specific section that was a there was a
bug in the system that would not allow
us to make correct decisions which is
the fact that a count for the the time
sunday times is usually owned by the
head of the family with our consumers
they are tend to be conservative they
tend to be male-dominated families and
so a woman would be logged in as her
husband the vast majority of her female
users will be logged in as their husband
and then that may make
different decisions first we're like
well we can't make decisions for female
users but we can maybe look at our
product and say do we want a family
log-in with one login book with multiple
users to try and track this okay this is
actually from my time at the Guardian on
the interactive team this is a us-based
story this is based on the US food aid
program this was a time where the u.s.
budgets were being slashed at
post-recession and they ring-fence the
US food aid budget and in Congress and
the reason why they said they
ring-fenced it was because of the
recession the US food aid program is
going to be used to bolster small farms
and small agricultural businesses that
they're going to be see a reduced in
volume and in order to survive they're
going to use the US food a program to
actually get their produce and send it
abroad and therefore bolster them so we
ended up building an interactive and we
chased procurement reports to actually
shipping reports it was very interesting
we found an FTP site just with folders
that was used for shipping companies to
track their shipment because it was open
we were able to go in and get port
reports of what is coming in on the
container docks from there we tracked
each food shipment and what they were
back to the the country from which the
food a program is being run I want to
ask you now considering this is data
across multiple websites this is scrape
data this is data from multiple sources
this is something not necessarily
provided the government don't track this
themselves that being said hands up who
thinks this is a story this is something
legitimate that you can make decisions
on for the US food aid budget how many
people think there's a bug in this
this was actually a legitimate story and
this was brought up in Congress when
they debated their next budget this
particular story the reason why this is
a particularly this was for sure a story
is that when you are aggregating data
and when you're doing things in joining
sources you need to have another metric
which way you can gauge against a
logical value for your conclusion that
being said they didn't track everything
they didn't track all their procurement
cords and who was getting the money but
they did have a us food aid budget for
that year how much are they going to the
government going to give in form of us
food aid and adding all of that up we
were related ten percent error and
that's kind of what you have to do
whenever you're making something
whenever I'm doing on a project and
doing analysis on user data I will
always say does this make sense as a
percentage considering what you know
working with your user data of
completion rates I will always find
another metric that will try and make
some logic out of it another reason why
this was particularly a good story and a
big lesson I learned from it is renamed
large agribusinesses that was the big
story here was that the u.s. food aid
that was ring-fenced for actually trying
to support local businesses was just
propping up large agribusinesses during
the recession and it was basically a
lobbying effort so we actually named
companies by naming companies um they
came down on us hard they threatened to
sue because we were also you also have
to look for comment before we published
the minute they knew we were publishing
this they got their lawyers on to us
really really large agribusinesses and
editors being editors flip out and
everyone on the investigation gets
called in a typical investigation not
using a computer probably around 20
people in six months a lot of the
companies they know if they threaten a
lawsuit we need to potentially go to
court which is being expensive we need
to show all of our work and we need to
reproduce all of our work that is money
and time intensive which is why
investigative journalism is is dying and
incredibly hard to do it's time and
money
I produced all of this on a virtual
machine I had a run dot SH bash file
that ran through all of my scripts when
I scraped everything from a website the
first thing I did take a snapshot of the
code that i downloaded with a time stamp
on it and so I basically told their cut
the the corporations and I told my
editor this is the file sent gets get
their companies to get a developer to
install virtualbox in vagrant and run
everything that I've done and within two
minutes I can reproduce the work that
I've done and the company's backed off
they backed off immediately and that's
another thing in terms of making
decisions based on data is
reproducibility it's almost scientific a
lot of science is very very difficult to
reproduce and if you're using big data
if you're making business decisions
oftentimes try and get someone even to
reproduce partial data if they're
finding that difficult then you have to
worry that there's a bug this was
reproducible and we had another metric
that showed that there was a it was
logical we weren't off by a factor of 10
and so that's why it was trustworthy
prescriptions data I'm not proud of this
story I don't want you to judge it by
the quality of the headline okay so bear
with me in the UK one of our cleanness
and largest data sets because the NHS is
owned by the government they actually
produce anonymized aggregated data of
its not even aggregate it's just
anonymized data of prescriptions it's
two gigs every month and so it's 60 gigs
for the year it's around 70 million
lines of CSV file the reason so this is
when i went to the times this
prescriptions data had come out months
previously and no one had published
anything on it and i wondered why that
was it's because a single file which you
download is two gigs which is too big to
open in Excel most yeah that's that's
exactly the answer also they working on
really old windows machines they don't
have enough RAM so they were saying yes
this is fantastic it's great but no one
can open this I'm like five program this
and go through it
so the prescriptions data I actually
managed to find two other data sets the
prescriptions data had a code for the
drug type really done very very well by
the NHS broken down and categorized for
every single type of drug you can think
of the chemical component and then
basically what the symptoms are four
fantastic data set so I was able to get
the prescriptions unable to fund the
prescription dataset decide and know
what type of drug was it being
prescribed for and then I found another
very interesting data set so each GP
surgery each doctor surgery has a unique
code on the NHS and the prescriptions
data had that code but in another data
set I got the code and I got the address
I also got a breakdown of their clients
in terms of how many males how many
females their age breakdowns as well so
I got a population breakdown so I
realized these massive datasets I can
manipulate and join so I was able to get
prescriptions data down to the
individual doctors surgery when you take
the telling the editors this they wanted
a map of erectile dysfunction drugs I
took don't judge it by the stroke don't
judge it by the story um that's the
first thing they wanted to see mostly it
was my fault because I was telling them
how good the drugs database was I was
telling them oh my god the NHS they've
coded everything we can get you know
anti-cancer drugs we can get heart
attack drugs we get a rectal this even
erectors rosa they're like erectile
dysfunction drugs that's the ones we
want oh we later went but this was the
first you said the prescription story so
we got it down to GP level and then we
needed to get the the males population
order to normalize the data because
we're getting this prescriptions which
has to do based on population so the
more concentrated the population the
harder the heat map it just when we were
just be mapping the population so we did
normalize the data and we did make a
heat map and we can make a heat map for
tons and tons of different types of
drugs including ADHD drugs and other
things a bit more interesting that being
said hands up who thinks this
is a legitimate story like don't don't
judge on the type of story legitimate
story who here thinks is a bug for a few
of you it's actually a bug but I didn't
give you all the information the clue
was in the granularity so we got
individual doctors surgery right and
some surgeries can be very small and
have a small population one of the
doctors surgeries is for the guards that
guard the crown jewels in the tower of
london these are yeoman they're all
quite old as you can see i'm not sure
who they think they're going to stop
stealing the crown jewels but we were
able to ice they that was the doctor
surgery that had the highest
concentration of erectile dysfunction
drugs because it was basically a doctor
surgery made of elderly men and
literally our editors wanted to go with
the headline her majesty's limb pissed
service we got into a massive massive
argument I'm like I know this data is
open and it's free and its government
will add to use it but we are breaking
privacy laws I ended up d anonymizing it
i was like no you can isolate
individuals from this you cannot do this
you cannot do this even if the data is
legit if you have terms and conditions
saying you guarantee anonymization you
guarantee privacy if UD anonymize it you
should not do that you should not make
business decisions off that you just
cannot do it and so what we did is we
had to then re a grenade it up to a
level where you cannot isolate I I so so
we went from GP level we had to get
mapping data onto constituencies and
aggregate it further up there using
mapping data but that was a real key
lesson learned it's actually a lot
easier to D anonymized data and if
you've DN own eyes data it is a bug it
is not a story you cannot use it the
next one I want to give you is actually
using census data just a big big data
set very very clean very very
trustworthy one thing we did is we
looked at the London population and UK
born a city
these verses non UK born and then from
there our data scientists did a linear
regression prediction that the non UK
born are going to outnumber the UK born
people in London by 2028 um the x is a
conservative paper they were pro-british
and they wanted to run with this hands
up who thinks that that is a legitimate
story this is census data or bug yeah
it's it's a nasty nasty bug um you
should never ever do predictions at all
like so many people model use
predictions and models for revenue and
it's basically they will pick whichever
model gives them the most revenue and
it's absolutely useless you should never
make any decisions off that mostly and
the thing I use not just that story and
fighting fighting our editors not to
publish this and not to use this and
literally like whacking the data slide
is over there going you knew you
shouldn't have done this just don't give
it to them save them from themselves um
the way I think about it is I've seen
two or three news articles actually
saying that women are going to run
faster than men using sports data that
being said this is data this is the men
and women's a 100 up at the top there
the blues the men's and that's the women
if you take a linear regression if you
take it over this snapshot in time you
will get that they will have done it by
like 1950 and if you use this you'll get
it by like twenty ten whenever you use a
linear regression you have no idea when
you should start with the data and when
you should end a census has it start in
an end but people and populations don't
there's also very very different
behaviors so with men and sports and
running they've literally reach
saturation point when it comes to how
much like health and Sport Science and
looking after their bodies they can
they're looking now for genetic freaks
like like Usain Bolt who's just
incredibly huge whereas women are in a
different time frame with that we still
have way more that we can progress and
so we can be a stage where it's linear
men can be at a stage where it's a step
it's an in star do a linear regression
it makes absolutely no sense very
different behaviors in the data that
being said I'm going to go to the last
one which actually does use algorithms
this is a the general election the last
general election even though we have a
new prime minister we have no general
election this is the last one where it's
got voted in and we use the random
forest algorithms to do a decision tree
post analysis of the breakdown of the
type of constituencies that voted labour
conservative or SNP as you can see the
first thing is are you in Scotland if so
you most likely voted SMP and that was
using polling data which in the UK isn't
the best quality but taking that into
account is doing something like this
legitimate as a story as opposed to a
linear regression a random forest
decision tree is it a story or is it a
bug I say this is a story one you are
not making predictions this is post
analysis these are the decisions you
want to make you don't want to make a
decision based on predicted revenue you
want to make a decision based on what
led your revenue to be particularly what
it was on certain days is it a sort of
thing where there was a in sales or was
a weather thing then you should make
these decisions based on that the
interesting thing for this as well is um
even though its algorithm analysis if
anyone has done used random random
forest you can do pruning there are
actually quite a favorite of decisions
to make with this so this is kind of a
bit of a gray area but one thing is is
we knew the data we knew the story quite
well and secondly the really interesting
thing I liked about this as a story was
at first it was hugely difficult to
persuade editors to do something like
this to then this was very mathematical
they didn't like the idea of this so
what I actually did is um using Kaggle
data I and our I did a random forest
tree for the sinking of the Titanic
what was the biggest deciding factor for
someone on the Titanic to have lived in
have died that's something they can
understand I showed them a bit of the
steps and I showed them the tree being
made and from that they were like okay
we can do this with general action we
kind of understand it so knowing how it
works and applying it to something else
and explaining that to people explaining
that to your business people explaining
that to your QA people not leaving it in
the realms of a developer in a data
scientist will lead you and the whole
team to be able to make better decisions
later on and interesting ways to use
things because from that they allowed to
do it for the general election and my
editor who actually lives with me
actually said that come when they knew
breaks it was happening when that vote
was happening she's like the editors
actually came to our team begging us to
do this again so you know it took ages
to persuade them to do it we did it once
and then afterwards they started coming
back to you that being said I'm just
about out of time I'm girl meets code
that's my thought works address any
questions
the fact that people who vote actually
don't even look at policy very much
leads me to think that this probably
isn't going to influence them at all the
thing that it does interest me is how my
influence political parties and how they
campaign so one the big inspiration for
me to do that was Amanda Cox from the
New York Times did a random forest
algorithm decision tree for the previous
Democratic primaries that was Obama
versus Clinton and they showed the
decision tree of which states went for
Obama which says went for Clinton and
the one at the very top was is it over
twenty percent black population went
straight for Obama and so if you are
thinking of electioneering like that
doing that post analysis you would
concentrate on the nodes further down on
the trees on the switches that made a
small percentage some of them had to do
with education and listening had to do
with society and societies in the
decision tree we did it actually was
more so who owns property if they own
their own property rather than actually
being wealthy that would change the way
that they voted which tells government
if you were empowering you want to stay
in power this is what you do is you make
sure more people are home owners or for
Clinton you make sure people you try and
get populations to pry population to
publish in black areas more educated and
for me that was what was interesting
because most of it was there was always
a positive way on society that led to
the right outcome the outcome of the
people who got in so that's where I
think it would be interesting and that's
where I think it would be interesting in
terms of businesses as well doing that
post analysis on their data to decide
how best to treat their customers there
was a question over here as well oh
um that's basically from training your
nose just from working with lots and
lots of stuff that's what I find a lot
of data scientists who work with large
data they don't necessarily get the nose
I've been whenever I work with data
there's always something that I'm like
that just doesn't smell right it's the
same way as a journalist they're kind of
job on their beat is to kind of think
this is this person bullshitting me or
they're being really evasive maybe I
should try around this room and get
something just from working with messy
data human-made data government data on
a small level when you do on a big level
and you use Hadoop and spark and you
shard things you don't get that view
actually digging down into it you just
kind of get this sense which is
something like I particularly like doing
I think it's really really fun and it's
kind of problem solving another thing is
um I didn't propose the talk for this
this strange loop but I have done it
previously I'm going to do it in Wharton
Business School I do it [ __ ] called
data science [ __ ] which is all of
the [ __ ] that you can come across of
the pitfalls and a lot of it has to do
which is understanding like
distributions looking at data that
trying trying to find out how clean data
is and how you can lose data and it's
just about working with it
yeah what we realized was don't give it
to them save it from themselves we would
keep it to a small group of people and
then only allow what we think is legit
in because that's something we learned
very early on like with the
prescriptions data and with things like
that we realized that once we presented
them they would they would just hook
onto something we would give them we
would give them a broad overview and
it's like no just give them an arrow
overview that being said one thing I
realize is that if you leave the data
knowledge and the statistical knowledge
to the nerds to the data scientists and
the programmers that's when it gets very
very dangerous because they need also
the knowledge of what is a legitimate
business value and 0 as well as that the
people up high they need to be able to
try and spot issues in the data they
need to understand when things should be
reproducible because working with data
and cleaning with data can be a real
pain and a lot of the times corners are
cut or things are missed because you can
pump something into an algorithm and
I'll produce something out it's not like
you'll try multiply two words and your
compiler will just say no this makes no
sense you so much stuff that you can do
you can do and it will allow you to do
and it's just along the way whether it
makes sense from the way it was
collected the way it was cleaned and so
again my data science [ __ ] talk what
I kind of say is that this is not for
developers this is for QA and for
business people because they don't need
to know the hard maths but they need to
know where the cracks are that bad
things tend to leak through and that's
what I found out like working with data
even on a small or medium scale
prescriptions was that most medium data
wasn't even big data just wouldn't fit
in like Excel that's something that I've
learned but when you look at it in a
large large scale you don't see the
cracks it just kind of smoothes out and
so looking at things on a smaller scale
just gives you that bit more sense
I think we're just about done as well
okay um I will tomorrow I'll be wearing
my fault works t-shirt and probably be
at the thought works both as well so
come grab me if you have any questions I
want to talk more